♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE WILL CONTINUE AT
THIS HOUR 9 MINUTES BEFORE
10:00 P.M. EASTERN TIME AND THAT
OF COURSE 7:00 P.M. ON THE
WEST COAST MONITORING TO PROTEST
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
LIFE PICTURE FROM PHOENIX,
NEW YORK AND WE WILL BRING LIGHT
REPORTS AS NEWS DEVELOPS.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY A
BOMBSHELL, ROD ROSENSTEIN, YEP
HE HAS A GUIDE THAT APPOINTED
MUELLER.
HE IS THE GUY THAT SIGNED THE
FOURTH BUYS A WARRANT AND FOURTH
RENEWAL AND THAT GUY WHO SENT
SCOPE MEMORANDUM TO BOB MUELLER
TO INVESTIGATE HIS TESTIMONY
TODAY, NO COLLUSION, NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
HIS QUOTE, NOT SURE IF EVEN READ
THE WHOLE PART OF CARTER/PAGE
BUYS APPLICATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
YOU ARE KIDDING ME?
WE NOW KNOW RUSSIAN INFORMATION
PAID FOR BY HILLARY AND WITHOUT
WHICH THERE WAS NO FISA
APPLICATION, TAKE A LOOK.
>> YES WE WERE READING THE FISA.
THERE IS A LOT OF FISA
APPLICATIONS THAT COME THROUGH
AND MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN OTHERS
BUT THIS ONE UNUSUAL BECAUSE I
ALREADY KNEW ABOUT IT BECAUSE OF
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
MOST OF THE FISA APPLICATION
REPRESENTED TO ME I AM THE LAST
PLACE BEFORE FILED TO THE COURT
AND I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THEM.
THIS WHEN I KNEW A FAIR AMOUNT
ABOUT IT AND I’M NOT SURE I READ
EVERY PAGE BUT I KNEW WHAT WAS
IN IT.
>> Sean: OKAY, DESPITE ALL
THIS, ROSENSTEIN STILL, REMEMBER
WE ALREADY HAD DEBUNKED STARTING
JANUARY 21ST, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
FINALLY GOT AROUND TO VERIFY
HILLARY’S MISINFORMATION RUSSIAN
PAID FOR.
THEY FOUND THE SUB SOURCE DIDN’T
BACKUP STILL, STILL DIDN’T
BACKUP STEEL PIER THAT MEAN HE
APPOINTED THIS GUY FOR NO
REASON PUTTING THE COUNTRY
AND THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR HIM TO
AND A HALF YEARS TO WHICH HE
SAYS HE WOULDN’T DO NOW.
JOINING US WITH REACTION LEADING
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
I CAN’T BELIEVE WHAT I HEARD
TODAY.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THAT HIM BY THE
WAY THOSE PEOPLE THAT SAY WHERE
IS LINDSAY?
YOU TALKING ABOUT NOT GETTING IT
DONE BUT YOU ARE TALKING AND
IT’S ONLY THE BEGINNING.
>> YES A FIRST STEP IN JOURNEY
THAT WILL END IN OCTOBER TO TRY
TO EXPLAIN TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HOW THE HELL DID THIS
HAPPEN.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THE FBI AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEFRAUDED THE FISA COURT MANY
TIMES AND NOBODY KNEW ABOUT IT.
WHAT DID ROD ROSENSTEIN SAY?
IF I KNEW THEN WHAT I KNOW NOW,
I WOULD NOT HAVE SIGNED THE
WARRANT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE SAID THAT?
IF YOU KNEW THE SUB SOURCE HAD
TOLD THE FBI THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE AND YOU
SIGNED THE WARRANT ANYWAY, YOU
ARE IT CAN ATTEMPT TO GO TO
JAIL.
BUT THE MOST TELLING THING TO ME
WAS THE SCOPE MEMO OUTLINING
WHAT MUELLER COULD DO WAS
PREPARED BY THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
DEFRAUDED THE COURT.
THE FOX GUARDING THE HEN HOUSE.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT LIED TO THE
COURT SET UP A MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IT WASN’T ROSENSTEIN.
IT WAS THE PEOPLE WHO LIED TO
THE COURT AND MANIPULATED THE
EVIDENCE, SET UP THE WHOLE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: IS THIS A COUP,
SENATOR?
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE A COUP
ATTEMPT.
>> STAY TUNED.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, WE KNOW THAT
GENERAL FLYNN WAS NOT WORKING
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
JANUARY 4, 2017, THEY WANTED TO
TAKE HIM NOT AT CROSS CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE BUT IN AUGUST, WHY IS
HIS NAME STILL THERE?
WE KNOW CARTER PAGE WAS NO MORE
A RUSSIAN AGENT AS I AM A
CHINESE ASTRONAUT.
WE KNOW THE DOSSIER AGAINST
CARTER PAGE WAS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE.
THEY DO THAT JANUARY 2017.
WHY WAS HIS NAME LISTED IN
AUGUST 2017?
>> Sean: SENATOR COME IF YOU
DIDN’T HAVE SUCH UNREST IN ALL O
THIS HAPPENING, THIS IS THE